black mirror season 5 is here with a
stack of Easter eggs and shared universe
connections to many previous episodes
including sang Junipero 15 million
merits Bandersnatch and white Christmas
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
today i'm revealing all the crucial
details you might have missed in the
fifth season and my theory on how all
the episodes connect together obviously
black mirror spoilers ahead so take care
the striking Vipers episode examines
what happens when two old college
friends Danny and Karl reconnect later
in life when Karl buys Danny the new
striking Vipers X video game as Danny
goes to open the box with the VR add-on
we can see that it's manufactured by TCK
our systems
TCK our is the neural technology company
responsible for the simulated reality
Tech in San Junipero and is also the
company which conducted medical
experiments outta st. junipers hospital
in the black museum episode the way that
the striking Viper X game emulates
physical sensations means it could also
be linked to another piece of TCK our
tech the sim fatik diagnosis that dr.
Peter Dawson used to experience his
subjects pain and pleasure in black
Museum
turns out we haven't discovered how to
share knowledge with physical sensations
being gone
now even though Karl and Danny
experienced the pain from the sensations
in the game there isn't any lasting
physical effect on them or they game
characters don't worry he resets nor I'm
done it's very similar to how whoever
wears a sim Phatak diagnose it doesn't
suffer any lasting injury either I mean
not seriously
Hector felt the burn but took no damage
at all all of the experience none of the
physical cost and there's even a
parallel to how Kyle feels as a woman
when he's in the game without dr. Lawson
experience both male and female orgasms
when you use the synthetic diagnosed a
witness girlfriend how does it feel
being in the woman's body like one's a
guitar so no the are very so whole in
Orchestra the striking Vipers game also
gets referenced in the Rachel Jack and
Ashley 2 episode of season 5 during a
news report about Ashley O's coma a
ticker on-screen mentions that saito
game whose shares have jumped after the
release of striking Vipers saito game uu
is the company first seen in the play
test episode which hired
/ redfield as a video game tester and
their work on augmented reality games
ties back clearly to striking Vipers X
what we're working on is an interactive
augmented reality system like VR more
like layers on top of reality the little
round head piece that Danny and Carl
were to play striking Vipers isn't
totally dissimilar to the mushroom that
Saito gamo implanted in Cooper either
that mushroom malfunctioned though
leading to Cooper's death and it looks
like that tech from play test may have
been replaced with the little button
that Danny and Carl use and striking
vipers that little disc made by TCK are
for striking vipers eggs may also be a
version of the devices used in San
Junipero and the way striking Vipers X
brings old friends Danny and Carl back
together in an unconventional way they
also fulfill the edge magazine headline
in play test that TCK R would turn
nostalgia into a game it's a humorous
moment when the Ashley to doll has her
4% brain limiter raised and the full
unfiltered consciousness of Ashley o is
unleashed and we next learn that the
little doll actually has an entire
digital copy of Ashley's mind this isn't
the first time we've seen consciousness
replicated on black mirror and Ashley -
maybe an early form of the cookie
technology we see in white Christmas
where Greta has her mind copied into a
cookie so it can perform her household
chores
in fact the robot believes she is a real
version of Ashley much like grasses
cookie did - you're really Ashley oh
yeah I am really really the way Ashley
argues over whether Ashley - is really
an individual character as an early
indicator of how cookies and other black
mirror episodes are treated as slaves
without any rights and are even
horrendously tortured most people would
say she's only made a code she's not
real
I can't believe there's two of you thing
isn't all of me I'm all of me that issue
was later addressed in the hated in the
nation episode where a news ticker
announced that cookies have been
declared to have human rights the drug
that Ashley owes aren't her managers
give her to keep her docile and stop her
from acting
could be what's in the compliance drink
that the contestants on hotshots in the
50 million merits episode are made to
drink before going on stage compliance
no thanks yes thanks it's compulsory for
contestants and IB cons song anyone who
knows what love is which she sings on
hotshots
pops up during the exclusive report on
Ashley o to demonstrate how her arm to
manage as a using voice mimicry software
to vocalize Ashley's voice recordings
into brand new songs and after Ashley is
deliberately poisoned by her aunt
USN reports that she's been rushed to
st. junipers ICU
st. junipers has come up a few times in
black mirror it's the hospital from
black Museum where Rallo Haynes used to
work and in Bandersnatch Stephan visits
a different doctor Haynes at the st.
junipers medical facility the name Saint
juniper also likely links back to the
fan favorite episode sang Junipero which
fittingly for Ashley's story features
people who are dead in the real world
while they're alive in their own virtual
reality earlier in the episode an eerily
familiar ad plays on the TV and Rachel
and Jack's bedroom live breathe smell
willow grain were the manufacturers of
the memory recording neural implants
that featured in the entire history of
you and which allowed people to replay
memories either on screens or in front
of their own eyes because memory is
because memory is for living after the
ad the fun to tame and daily show comes
on and the host mentions a sea of
tranquility reboot sea of tranquility is
the black Murray Universe HBO show that
was mentioned in the very first episode
of the series the national anthem no won
an Emmy for his effects work on that HBO
Moon Western things here tranquility and
cosplayer fans of that TV show also
appeared in the nosedive episode of
season 3 the front attainment presenter
also talks about tusk making a boo-boo
on a British TV show and the scene taken
directly from the hated in the nation
episode appears on the TV screens in
that scene the rapper tusk went on a
rant and insulted a young fan of his on
the program and this news report
suggests that both black mera episodes
probably take place around the same time
the USN news tickers in the Ashleigh 2
episode also help establish where the
events may occur in relation to other
black mirror episodes for example one
headline reads museum owners body found
in smoking ruins referring to the end of
the black museum episode where Rallo
Haynes and his museum were burned down
another ticker announces an architect
has been arrested on multiple murder
charges
this likely relates to Mia Nolan the
architect from the crocodile episode who
is about to be apprehended by police at
the end of that story
Colin Richman the game programmer played
by will Poulter in Bandersnatch also
gets a shout-out in the name of Rachel
school rip man high as the smithereens
well it's absolutely loaded with Easter
eggs and references to other black
mirror episodes if we examine the
rideshare apps map on Chris's phone more
closely we can see that the smithereen
UK office is located near fences pizza
which previously appeared in the
episodes USS Callister and crocodile
welcome Betts's pizza
your pizza is ready for collection and
there's an empty fences pizza box at
Chris's house when the police visit to
investigate back on the map of locations
near smithereens UK office is the Medina
Plaza Hotel which is where offenses
Pizza driverless vehicle was involved in
an accident in the crocodile episode
black Morris Bank national allied also
has a branch nearby and the bank has
appeared previously in both shut up and
dance and play tests and appropriately
enough the video game company Saito game
ooh has an arcade nearby other location
Easter eggs in the area include blessed
O Park a reference to actress Alice Eve
character know me blessed Oh from
nose-dive Redfield theatre a nod to act
a Wyatt Russell's character Cooper
Redfield from play tests there's a
Dawson burger bar a reference to dr.
Peter Dawson from black Museum numerous
characters from men against fire also
gets a shout out there's Atelier
Arquette a nod to the antagonist
Arquette who's played by actor Michael
Kelly stripes cocktail bar references
actor malachi Kirby's character stripe
and Ryman's tips its hat to actress
Madeleine Brewers character Ryman aka
hunter the street outside smithereens
officers called ghilane street and
easter eggs victorious ghilane from the
white berapa sewed opposite the office
is the Bandersnatch theatre a hat tip to
the interactive
choose-your-own-adventure episode and
smithereen was itself referenced in the
pal ripman ending to Bandersnatch where
a UK and news ticker stated that a
senate committee was grilling Bauer over
Russian BOTS this ticker also refers to
real-life events in 2018 were the heads
of social media companies testified
before the US Senate about Russian
interference in u.s. elections and the
fake accounts being created on these
platforms and although Billy Bower the
head of smithereen isn't supposed to be
based on any specific real-life person
Charlie Brooker the creator of black
mirror told aw that he thought it was
interesting that last year Jack Dorsey
the CEO of Twitter had tweeted he'd gone
on a 10-day silent retreat inside the
smithereen UK office is a huge screen
packed with headlines and hashtags
referencing numerous other black mirror
episodes and moments first up there's a
headline that Prime Minister
is meeting with EU negotiators and on
the hashtag wall or some related
trending topics such as hashtag oink
oink allo referring to the national
anthem episode where the PM michael
callow was blackmailed into having sex
with a pig related to that is a snout
rage hashtag which refers to the
uncannily similar real-life allegation
the former British Prime Minister David
Cameron placed a private part of his
Anatomy into the mouth of a dead pig
during an initiation ceremony for an
Oxford University Dining Society snout
rage was one of the hashtags among
others which trended on Twitter when the
allegation became public the site Oh gay
moon trending hashtags may refer to the
company's release of striking vipers or
it could suggest a collaboration with
Netflix which was hinted at in the Perl
rip moon ending to Bandersnatch
hashtag Ashley Oh Wembley obviously
refers to Miley Cyrus's character Ashley
oath who's probably playing a concert at
Wembley at the time of this episode and
hashtag Sea of Tranquility reboot
relates to that entertainment news
announcement in the Rachel Jack and
Ashley 2 episode hashtag Tucker is also
trending which could have multiple
meanings in the black mirror universe
this Tucker's bar from San Junipero the
software company Tucker soft from
Bandersnatch and Tucker may also be a
popular way of reading the acronym for
TC KR systems
hashtag st. junipers strike is another
st. junipers reference and the other two
hashtags the bargain hunt and goggle box
which for any non Brits watching this
video for two real-life British reality
TV shows after Chris demands to speak to
Billy Bower one of the smithereen
managers in London goes to call the u.s.
office and as she Scrolls through her
phone it reveals a huge list of other
black mirror characters a few I spotted
a Bing from 50 million merits Cooper
from play tests do Donny from USS
Callister
Greta from white Christmas Hector from
shut up and dance Lacey from nosedive
Liam from the entire history of you and
nish from black museum and there's a fun
little meta Easter egg when the phone
callers patch through and smithereens
u.s. HQ is revealed to be in Los Gatos
California which is also the location of
Netflix's headquarters so did you spot
any other interesting details Easter
eggs or connections in the new season of
Black Mirror in which we
your favorite episode in season 5 leave
your thoughts in the comments below for
another shared universe video tapleft to
learn exactly how Jordan peels arson get
out movies are connected or tap write
for another video you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time you pick a movie lovers